the biggest question leading into the
release of Marvel's superhero
blockbuster Black Panther was can it
possibly live up to the massive amount
of hype well that question has been
answered with a resounding yes as
millions of fans around the world can
attest but as great as the film is there
are some other questions that never
quite got around to addressing so grab
your vibranium and hold on tight because
here's a spoiler filled look at some of
the biggest unanswered questions in
black panther why didn't they bring the
kid to Wakanda after King takaka kills
his brother he heads home to Wakanda
leaving his suddenly orphaned nephew
Erik behind in Oakland this ends up
being a terrible mistake as the invented
boy grows up to be the conquering
invader kill manga sure hindsight is
20/20 but you have to ask why did takaka
leave the boy behind in the film it said
multiple times that he did it to protect
the veil of secrecy surrounding Wakanda
but how exactly would adopting an
orphaned little boy threaten national
security it doesn't seem like anybody in
Oakland would have missed him and
bringing the child and his father's body
back to Wakanda would have tied up loose
ends instead of leaving them plus it's
just the right thing to do leaving the
boy behind is a real head-scratcher not
to mention a total jerk move is to
chawla the last Black Panther in a
pivotal scene after kill monger becomes
the new king of Wakanda he orders the
botanists in the garden of heart-shaped
herbs to burn the country's entire
supply of the magic plant that gives
their monarchs the power of the Black
Panther
so does that actually mean that T'Challa
is the last of the Black Panthers the
comics tell us that the super plants
exist in the first place because
vibranium mutates the local flora so
wouldn't the presence of a massive
mountain of vibranium mean it would just
create more plus Nakia shows just how
easy it is to simply walk out the door
with one in your pocket so there could
be a supply pretty much anywhere but is
there or is this the end of the Black
Panther legacy we just don't know enough
about how the whole Black Panther thing
works to say speaking of which how does
the whole Black Panther thing work so
according to the movie the powers of the
Panther goddess bast are bestowed upon
the reigning monarch of Wakanda after
they eat the magic heart-shaped earth
then the monarch is buried alive while
their spirit travels to the afterlife to
commune with the spirits of their
ancestors before being reborn as
the Black Panther one big question
though in Captain America Civil War it
seems as though to chawla has already
become the black panther before his
father's death
something verified by the official
prequel comics so who exactly can become
Black Panther the movie suggests only
the king is allowed to eat the
heart-shaped herb but that's clearly not
true
it doesn't seem hereditary either
considering the kingship is sometimes
determined by ritual combat and not
bloodlines so can anyone become Black
Panther if the king appoints them to the
role and if so doesn't it seem negligent
for the nation's supreme leader to be
constantly courting death by battling
supervillains instead of delegating that
responsibility to someone more
expendable this is one area where we're
more confused than before the movie
started
what is vibranium actually do it's
supposed to be the hardest metal in the
world
but vibranium also seems to have magic
powers like mutating the plants in
Wakanda and enabling Wakanda and
technology to do all sorts of random
things that well maybe don't make much
sense for instance how does jamming a
wad of vibranium into an open gunshot
wound stabilizes spinal injury it seems
as though vibranium main property is
covering over clot holes which makes it
a very valuable resource indeed and then
there's that suit does every Marvel hero
need a super suit thanks to the
heart-shaped herb Black Panther
possesses inhuman speed agility strength
and stamina yet over the course of black
panther most of the major butt kicking
moves he pulls off during the fight
scenes are possible because he's wearing
a technologically advanced super suit
that allows him to stop bullets and then
redirect the absorb kinetic energy into
concussive blasts which would be totally
cool in Iron Man 4 but does every single
Marvel hero need a super suit it's fine
for Iron Man and war machine and Ant Man
and the wasp and the Falcon but when
Marvel sticks characters like spider-man
and Black Panther into super suits it
all starts to feel very save me say me
and ironically the most compelling and
gripping fights in Black Panther are the
ritual challenges where T'Challa
is stripped of his powers and gizmos so
why does Marvel insist on giving
everyone these super suits
T'Challa seems pretty superb without it
you know how does Wakanda function
according to the movie while Conda has
been isolated for centuries hi
itself away to make sure nobody else
gets any of its precious vibranium but
if they're unwilling to trade their most
valuable resource where do they get
everything else
sure vibranium can do all sorts of
amazing things but you can't build an
entire technologically superior society
out of one Rock can you they seem to
have a massive amount of wealth but
where does it come from if they really
are as isolated as they claim to be and
if they're so peaceful and insular why
exactly do they have enclaves of highly
trained spies and soldiers secretly
stationed in all the major centers of
the world and not just major centers
they also have so many war dogs around
the world that they even have a base in
Oakland which isn't even among the top
1,000 largest cities in the world so why
does Wakanda have such an extensive
worldwide military operation now what
may be the biggest question left
unanswered from Black Panther is one
they never intended to answer in this
movie namely what comes next we know
from the trailer to Avengers infinity
war that Thanos is going to attack
Wakanda presumably because an infinity
stone is there or somehow ends up there
we also know from the trailer that
Captain America and a team of Avengers
are on hand in Wakanda when this happens
so how does that all come about and
what's going to happen to T'Challa and
Wakanda is their big push to become an
open nation going to end before it even
gets a chance to start or are they just
gonna be left sharing a huge pile of
rubble it seems there's only one way to
find out and all we can say is that we
can't wait to see what unanswered
questions are still left after we watch
Avengers infinity war and black panther
2 thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Applause]
[Music]
you